Transcriptor: Ilze Garda
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
(Music)
(Inglés) Greek dance, Tour de France
Appenzeller, football fans,
Colossus of Rhodes,
Magic dragon Amsterdam,
Swiss watches, beer bars,
Döner kebab, sauna,
Flamenco, help for Africa,
Yves St. Laurent the mega star,
Croatian Islands, Mozart,
Spring of Prague, German cars,
BB lips, pommes frites,
Norwegian fjord and Coldplay hits,
Scottish kilt, oild rigs,
The Irish and St. Patrick's,
French wine and Spanish wine,
Italian wine and Neuschwanstein.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
¿No es inquietante Europa?
¿No es emocionante Europa?
El romanticismo de París,
la bohemia de Praga,
la moda de Milán, la locura de Berlín,
el diseño de Barcelona.
A mí me encanta Europa,
estoy enamorado de Europa.
¿Y vosotros? ¿Os encanta Europa?
Público: ¡Sí!
¿Por qué entonces
hay mucha gente fuera ahí
que no está de acuerdo con nosotros?
Para ellos Europa no es inquietante,
para ellos Europa es
aburrido, burocrático,
crisis, gastos fiscales, amenaza.
Para mí Europa siempre ha sido
un campo de fútbol.
Sí, somos todos muy diferentes,
pero llevamos el mismo jersey.
Con un pasaporte sólo
podemos movernos libremente
por todo el campo.
Seguimos las mismas reglas:
un saque de banda en Portugal
es un un saque de banda en Polonia.
Y aun así tenemos un problema.
El pase de defensa de Portugal
no llega al mediocampista de Letonia.
Y el pase del centrocampista de Francia
no llega al delantero sueco.
¿Por qué?
¿Por qué no llega?
Os voy a decirlo. No se conocen.
No nos conocemos.
Yo una vez he jugado en un equipo
donde sí nos conocíamos todos
y siempre ganamos.
¡No era el Barça!
Siempre ganamos porque nos conocíamos,
muy distintos, muy diversos,
pero sí, nos conocíamos,
y este equipo se llama Erasmus.
(Risas)
Sí, soy víctima del programa Erasmus.
¿Quiénes de vosotros habéis hecho
un Erasmus aquí en esta sala?
Hombre, ¡cuántos europeos! Muy bien.
Erasmus es fantástico porque ahí
sí existe un espíritu común europeo.
Lo vivimos en las fiestas.
El belga peleando con el bávaro
quién hace la mejor cerveza.
Esto une.
(Risas)
Era fantástico.
Llegamos de diferentes sitios de Europa
a un sitio - ciudad, universidad -
y llegamos conjuntamente
a la idea europea.
¿Cómo lo hace la Unión Europea hoy en día,
el promover de la idea
de un espíritu común?
De arriba a abajo. Es el lado izquiérdo.
Hay muchas iniciativas, claro.
No obstante, celebramos
los 50 años de los [Tratados] de Roma
el 25 de marzo de 2007
en Berlín con berlineses.
Y en Francia, con la gente de París.
En Italia, con la gente de Roma.
¿Esto es el acercamiento más poderoso
para crear un espíritu común?
El día 5 de octubre de 2006
aquí en Barcelona,
en calle Aribau, nació la idea.
¿Por qué no lo hacemos al revés?
¿Por qué no llevamos
la gente de toda Europa
a través de una plataforma a un sitio,
hacía la idea europea como en el Erasmus?
Era una idea sencilla,
una idea banal, una idea absurda.
Pero como dice Albert Einstein:
"Si al principio una idea no es
absurda, no merece la pena."
Nació la idea de crear
The Festival. One Week, One Europe.
Es esta plataforma donde la gente va
de toda Europa para unirse en un sitio
y vivir, experimentar, disfrutar
Europa conjuntamente.
The Festival es la plataforma
no política - no política -
donde la gente va sin miedo
a llegar a nuevos horizontes.
Es la plataforma que se celebrará
cada dos años en otra metrópolis europea
para hacerlo un evento verdadero europeo.
¿Cuándo es? ¿Queréis ir, verdad?
¿Cuándo es?
(Risas)
No puedo ver. Pues, lo bueno
se hace esperar.
Si entráis en nuestra página web
- hoy, esta mañana -
de thefestival.eu vais a ver julio 2011.
Lo bueno se hace esperar.
Con esta charla
- voy a comunicarlo al Internet también -
vamos al julio 2012.
(Risas)
¿Y dónde podríamos empezar?
En una ciudad igual céntrica
de Europa para hacerlo más facil.
Una ciudad vibrante. Una ciudad de cambio.
Una ciudad como...
Berlín.
(Risas)
Muy bueno.
Berlín tiene todo.
Tiene espacio, tiene experiencia
con eventos de gran tamaño,
y tiene más españoles
que la ciudad de Zaragoza.
(Risas)
No estoy seguro,
pero así se siente allí.
(Risas)
Pues, es el punto
que tenemos
una idea absurda,
una fecha nueva y mejor
y una ciudad vibrante
para lanzar el viaje europeo.
Ahora todo el mundo me pregunta
la pregunta del millón:
"Y por qué debería ir?"
Por qué debería ir...
Les ofrecemos una experiencia
que nunca han tenido,
una experiencia europea,
ir a nuevos horizontes, nuevas facetas
de la vida, hacer amigos [multiculturales]
y formar parte de un espíritu
de equipo que nunca existía,
y no es suficiente.
Ellos quieren pan y circo.
Y nuestro circo tiene seis pilares.
Conjuntamente, gente de toda Europa
vamos a ver el arte de Europa;
vamos a comer la magnífica
comida de Europa;
vamos a ver el nuevo talento
de moda de Europa;
vamos a vivir Europa a través
de nuestras grandes películas
como de Álmodovar o "La vida es bella";
vamos a escuchar la mejor
música del continente;
vamos a compartir
nuestra pasión de deporte.
Seis temas, seis intereses
comunes, un campo común.
Y los 657 taxistas que he hablado
de este hace tres años dicen:
"¡Es una buena iniciativa!"
(Risas)
Y luego me pregunta también:
"¿Y quién va?"
(Risas)
¿Quién va?
En cuatro años teníamos
muchas definiciones:
la Unión Europea, el Council Europeo,
la versión geográfica.
Los departamentos de marketing
quieren saber "de 18 a 40".
¡No!
Un señor de India nos abrió los ojos,
un señor de India que escribió
un post en la página web y dijó:
"Yo también me siento europeo.
Yo y mi familia vivimos
muchos años en Europa,
yo también quiero ir al Festival. ¿Puedo?"
¿Vamos a excluir al señor de India?
No. Vamos a invitar a toda la gente
que se siente europea,
y ya no tenemos problemas
con la Unión o con el Council.
Todo el mundo que se siente europeo.
Pues, ahora tenemos gente que se siente
europea y quiere ir en 2012 a Berlín,
a una ciudad vibrante,
a la fiesta europea,
pero, claro, hacen falta
recursos para hacerlo.
Peleamos dos años ya con marcas
y medios para hacerlo factible,
y hemos decidido que nuestra M no sea
la marca de este momento, ni los medios,
hay una tercera M que nos interesa.
Aquí está Tony Anagor, un amigo,
y su amigo Simon Lingard
de Inglaterra una vez nos dijo:
"Chicos, lo que estáis haciendo
no es un evento, es un movimiento."
La tercera M es el movimiento
porque la gente va a mover
los medios y las marcas
y no al revés.
Porque un movimiento no se puede forzar,
un [movimiento] crece por la gente
que cree en esta misma idea.
Ya tenemos embajadores,
voces que apoyan,
que creen en este movimiento,
estrellas locales.
Y ya veo, ya os veo en los ojos.
Te veo, y te preguntas,
(Risas)
tú te preguntas: "¿Y dónde está U2?"
¡Jooo!
¿No se puede hacer un movimiento
en esta planeta sin U2?
(Risas)
Colin, tú eres de África.
El señor Bono está muy activo en África,
nosotros enfocamos Europa.
Estamos muy felices
de ya contar Sarah Connor
que sí ha vendido en Alemania
unos 12 millones de discos,
o de la banda Brainstorm de Letonia
que toca delante de 45 000 personas.
Son heroes locales,
son voces que apoyan ya
este movimiento sin dinero.
¿Pero es la gente más importante
de este movimiento?
Si pregunto así, no.
(Risas)
Somos todos nosotros.
Y claro, cuando les digo a la gente--
"¿Cuántos fans de Facebook
tienes?" me preguntan.
Y yo digo: "Pues, hoy esta mañana 1 328."
"¿Tan pocos?"
Para mí no es poco
porque hace seis años
- imagínados Europa, un tema abstracto -
hace seis años, sin Facebook,
hubiera sido la cifra cero.
Hoy tenemos 1 328 personas
que ya creen en esta idea.
¡Es muchísimo!
Y esta cifra puede hacer
una cosa - crecer.
Esta gente comparte nuestra visión.
¿Cuál es nuestra visión?
Empezó aquí hace quatro años
en calle Aribau en Barcelona con una idea.
El embajador de Alemania en Madrid
me dijo: "¡Tiene que hacerlo!"
Muy bien, así empezamos. (Risas)
Luego otra gente
les encantó la idea,
como a mis seis socios, todos europeos
de Berlín, todos alemanes.
Somos muy buenos en construir
coches y organizar eventos.
(Risas)
Y al final, este movimiento -
¿dónde vamos?
Vamos a dejar crecer este campo de fútbol
donde encima del campo
va a jugar un equipo
que juega mucho mejor que hoy,
porque eso es la visión - que tenemos
jugadores que se conozcan.
Que es nuestro problema -
no nos conocemos.
Ahí vamos a jugar.
¿Vamos a ganar siempre
como el Barça? No sé.
Pero seguro que vamos a jugar
mucho mejor que ahora,
y seguro que vamos a tener un espíritu
de equipo mucho mejor que ahora,
ye seguro que no vamos
a perder tan facilmente ya.
Vamos a tener un equipo mejor europeo.
Después de que Carlito aquí ha dicho
que no podemos motivar
a la gente ya a participar
porque la gente ya no quiere participar.
No voy a deciros que participéis.
Voy a invitaros a ser jardineros
(Risas)
y vamos a dejar
- y la última fila también -
vamos a dejar crecer este campo
donde jugamos todos mejores -
en Facebook, en la página web, todos.
Ahora somos una ONG,
estamos haciéndolo ahora mismo,
es para todos.
Y voy a terminar
con un sueño muy personal.
Yo soy ciudadano en esta gran
ciudad los últimos siete años,
de la Ciudad Condal.
Este proyecto tiene
sus inicios en Barcelona
y claro que sí - yo creo que Barcelona
como una ciudad muy vibrante,
como una ciudad inovadora,
como una ciudad
mediterranea, cosmopolita -
que nos gusta a todos que va a ser
una anfitriona algún día.
Igual en 2014,
(Risas)
igual en 2014, muy buena, perfecta
como lo a combrobado en el pasado,
Barcelona sí puede.
Yo les veo,
yo les veo a los miles y miles,
y miles de europeos,
que todos vienen aquí a Barcelona
y todos van a cantar juntos:
"Sí, somos europeos!"
(Aplausos)